ch for
[Music]
couple things the strike doesn't start
way out
there strikes are
closer strikes are when we're close to
hit okay
boom so we're close
Okay um
next thing is I get his arm going up
okay keep going
up so
up
up third thing one two tricep T of
insertion on the hand sword
triceps on the grip sword here don't
have two hands doing this
thing okay
one SP one curve Y
and
okay fourth thing at the top you move
him you see how I moved him because we
have to follow the rule that he goes
around
me so it don't come over here they come
down on top
up turn ever so
slightly make sure you get my hand
work this is what how I go from the
bottom to the top without
moving one more time you can't see my
back one push now you're on
top you always go bottom push to
top
uh next thing is on
UK watch your little IO
choreograph cell there is nothing in
this movement that turns the arm over
like we're doing
EO for EO or I have grabbed it and I
turned it do you see turn your arm
back there's resistance right that's
what I'm
using in this technique his hand was
going up it's going to hit me in the
head it comes straight down just up down
that's what his hand should
do I didn't stop it I went around it you
see you should come straight down
one more time up turn and straighten
just like it was
cutting okay let's get those things in
there stop turning your freaking hand on
this one okay so his energy is going
up and I'm going to match it and I'm
going to extend his upward
NE energy is going up I match it and I
extend it
don't go up and then he tries to come
down and then you try to turn
that energy goes up and I extend it it's
effortless leave the bottom part
out energy goes up and I extend it it's
so effortless then I don't have to move
my hands his arm moves and I stay up
with his on now I'm going to pin
this extend the upward
NE pin
[Music]
it boom
stand
home when you pin be near the elbow I'm
not a fan of playing with people's
wrists okay the wrist joint is very
small and it doesn't in real life does
not support people's body weight it'll
break but then they're standing still so
I like the
elbow the elbow can do
it
boom
boom okay
just that part again extend the up into
the circle if if I'm going up I want you
I want you to tell me which force you
think I'm
using uh when I extend the circle am I
just going to move my arm
over now okay I captured his whole body
his whole body moves we do it again
Watch how his Center moves you see
I'm not I'm not going here and I'm
trying to turn his arm I have to capture
her Center and the whole Center
move because so let's do this slowly so
he's you know he's going to be over here
you see and then I can take the arm back
on the 180 which is no longer the 180
and that's going to be outside his basis
support
you see that that's important because
the faster he's cutting down if you
think you're going to do these circles
you're crazy okay it's not going to
happen so you move him and now 180 is
good to go for the kadushi angle okay
and you're pinning it pick it up that's
what you're doing you're not here
floating you're pinning it
captur his whole body moves him here it
can drop on its original line of attack
all my weight is on it pick it up no
other hand in the
fight
capture
boom okay let's try it
again all right so this technique is
working on a person's reaction so
rewind the reaction of I'm shoving him
down he's going to pick it up
okay when you feel the resistance he
picks it up that's when I go you don't
pick up his
wrist okay up
turn down fix it up that's when you
go we're don't worry about the ending
now just
go k up that's when you go
it's it's not iido it's not j- jitsy
that I'm picking it up he picked it up
that's what gives the opening okay so
again our drill is
Boom top picks it up I go with
[Music]
itom it up I go with it
I don't lose connection and I don't
delay uh staying connected to it
okay hey the move the footw is not
important as much as the angle that you
have to take okay
[Music]
so he goes up I go with it I have to
stay on this back
corner that's where everything goes so
you can't
go in front and you're on this side now
you're going to get punched in the face
okay you can't go to the
front so you're doing the back outward
position and it's the same thing in C
your you see back
corner I had to move him with me so I
stay in the back corner okay and then I
can't turn him into the front
corner that's happening because the
shoulder is not locked and you're using
the ball and socket
joint lot of it's that'll almost always
happen if you stay at the wrist and now
he's forward
facing you have to lock the joint so
that shoulder moves with
you go
back so when you seize this you have to
seize the the center you can't you can't
stay in the limb and it's going to lean
you have to seize the center so his
energy was coming up and that's what I'm
seizing that
shoulder every part that's touching him
is doing that too
okay
sorry this way oh
so as I already said I want you to
attack the
elbow CU it's much easier to do all of
this leave right
angles in his
shoulder right angle in the
elbow right angle in the
wrist don't come to the shoulder like
shag don't don't open it up you'll bring
slack into the joint so everything is
here I'm not doing
this
this right
angles right
angles okay try it you should feel the
tightness in this joint you shouldn't
feel this as soon as his arm moves his
Center moves Okay Go Okay so I'm staying
I'm staying on the
elbow I'm
I'm throwing with the elbow this is what
I'm
doing so if you look at this
technique I have right angle on the
shoulder and on the elbow and on the
wrist so let's focus it on the wrist I
want this right angle and I'm pushing
that right
angle into the
technique so when we're
here and I come around it's just not
closed but it's right there but it's not
closed don't come here there's no power
here here all I got to do is that
throw the right
[Music]
angle then just obey your chu rule he
comes with me so he's
close moving his whole body so he can't
turn turn towards me turn turn turn this
way you see you're throwing momentum is
stopping
that via those locks so we're going to
focus in on this
hand I'm over here
here not here not here I'm not trying to
wrap it up this is wrapped
enough here at the forearm right angle
right angle boom bocks his body okay try
that again let's hurry up and move
on okay so you throw this tightness that
you're going to feel in the joint the
entire time so if you pay attention go
back rewind the fil
rewind okay the throw I'm going to throw
6 o' minimum and I'm shooting for
630 you see and so that my elbow touches
his elbow that's what I want rewind the
film if you out here like that see our
elbows are not touching and you go like
that our elbows are not touching go back
you want to keep
turning till your elbows touch and now
you have your control point so I just
change drop the elbow which I was doing
in the other techniques on the
throw 90 to where 6 6:30 so what happens
elbow tou elbow touches elbow there's
elbow touching elbow now I just dropping
that elbow picking up the other hand
is
sh